When I wrote about Jim Dooley
in Lisey’s Story, I was thinking
very much of the man
who shot John Lennon,
because this guy was a fan.
He was a huge fan of Lennon’s and
before shooting him to death,
he got Lennon to sign an album
and I thought to myself,
yeah, I can see that happening.
Dooley really looks at Scott’s novels
as like scripture, you know,
he lives by them, he breathes them.
They’re everything to him.
There was a lot of conversations
between Pablo and Stephen
and ultimately myself about
what to do with this character
and adding scenes to
make him something
more relatable and more real.
Dane is a very gifted actor that
can make a very simple sort of
regular scene into something very
complicated, just by his presence.
It’s easy to play a strong rock
villain that is just a mean person.
I think what Dane did so
beautifully is that he
was also able to create a fragile
man in this context of the villain.
And the fragility makes him vulnerable.
And that vulnerability, it's
fascinating because it's hard.
Prof.
This is amazing and it’s
only the tip of the iceberg,
there’s plenty more just waiting for us.
Look whatever it is I need you to stop.
Listen, listen, listen,
there’s a story in here about
a father and his two sons.
I’m pretty sure it’s the prequel
to The Coasters Daughter
he talked about it one time on NPR.
He’s fantastic. When
people read this they’re…
Where did you get it?
She gave it to me. Easy as pie.
Told you I was good
at persuading people.